et
[Musique]
notre invité politique ce matin 7 agnès
firmin le bodo bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous est la nouvelle minutes
elle est chargée de l'organisation
territoriale et des professionnels de
santé on verra ce que recouvre votre
ministère évidemment dans quelques
instants nous ensemble pendant 20
minutes point intervient en partenariat
avec la presse régionale représenter
entre la dépêche bonjour bonjour ryan
bonjour agnès firmin le bodo bonjour et
on va évidemment longuement parlé des
questions de santé agnès firmin le bodo
d'abord ce qui s'est passé cette nuit à
l'assemblée où les députés ont donc voté
le texte sur la crise sanitaire voter
mais largement remaniée ils ont
notamment rejeté la possibilité de
rétablir le pass sanitaires aux
frontières un site pour les voyages vers
les outre mer et la corse est un échec
pour le gouvernement
c'est un échec pour la santé des
français de voir
une partie
dlr s'allier avec le rassemblement
national et la nuque pour voter contre
la santé des français parce que c'était
bien l'objectif de ce pass foncière de
donner la possibilité c'était pas de le
rétablir c'est de donner la possibilité
au cas où la situation c'est dacia ne
serait plus si en variant arrivée dans
les pays frontaliers
ou très proches des pays de nos
territoires d'outre-mer la possibilité 2
c'est pas c'est pas contre le
gouvernement que la personne qui ont
voté contre ont voté c'est contre la
santé des français mais qu'est ce qui
s'est passé le texte n'a pas été
suffisamment préparée en avant en amont
pardon discuter avec ces groupes ce
texte a fait l'objet d'avancés puisque
en commission le gouvernement avait
promis de proposer la progression
jusqu'au 31 mars après la discussion et
la volonté de partager se caler sur six
mois nous sommes arrivés au 31 janvier à
l'unanimité allure mission dans
l'inhumanité de la commission
le député gosselin avait proposé
justement sur l'histoire de ce pass
munster que ce soit cela soit discuté
avec les exécutifs locaux l'amendement
qu'il a proposé un vérité a été votée
madame caramanlis avait proposé aussi
une avancée sur l'évolution du conseil
scientifique donc des propositions et
des avancées ont été faites et discuter
je rappelle que ce texte qui est le 13e
texte que l'assemblée examine
permettait justement depuis ce que nos
concitoyens et puisque les français sont
massivement vacciner nous pouvons vivre
avec le virus nous avons appris avec à
vivre avec le virus ce texte avait deux
articles l'un qui permettait de
continuer à vérifier l'évolution de
l'épidémie et c'est nécessaire et
l'autre qui permettait au gouvernement
si besoin est en fonction de l'évolution
de l'épidémie de pouvoir continuer à
protéger les français mais cela c'est ça
la preuve quand même que votre majorité
relative à ne va pas suffire à faire
passer vos réformes malgré volonté de
compromis et le fait que baisser et
trouver des majorités avec sartre s on
va bien que ça marche parce qu'on peut
constater c'est que sur un sujet qui
doit être trans partisan qui concerne
tout le monde la santé sur un sujet
comme la santé certains profitent de ce
premier texte de ce sujet pour en faire
jaillir un espèce de jeu contre le
gouvernement dit je le répète c'est bien
j'ai dit une partie des républicains qui
a qui a voté contre le texte et puis je
rappelle que nous sommes dans une
situation aussi où il manque encore des
députés puisque certains ont été nommés
ministres
une amende 20h40 22 donc mais je le
redis sur un sujet comme celui là qui
était un texte de loi qui permet qui
voilà qui permettait aussi de montrer
que nous avons appris à vivre à vivre
avec le virus
justement avec doute que deux articles
je le répète qui permettait d'y fixer
dans coup politique qui est je pense que
ça a tancé le montrer les autres
missions dont on voit quand on voit leur
est le rn et la nuque se féliciter et de
façon très démonstrative de fêter une
victoire contre le gouvernement ça n'est
pas une victoire contre le gouvernement
c'est la preuve que vous pouvez pas vous
appuyer sur le groupe ait l'air comme
vous sembliez l'espérer ces premières
semaines
écoutez c'est le premier texte nous
allons apprendre à travailler ensemble
et il le faut et moi j'aime ça va les
revoir la méthode avec la gère toute
confiance j'ai toute confiance dans le
fait que nous puissions texte par texte
arrivait à trouver j'allais dire des
compromis et avancer ensemble mais une
fois que les compromis ont été décidés
il faut les respecter jusqu'au bout sur
le fond du texte disait deux articles
dans ce texte est-ce que c'est pas un
peu légers alors que la septième vague
et faire choper avec les
hospitalisations repartent à la hausse
en justement nous avons
appris à vivre avec le virus une très
grande majorité de nos concitoyens sont
vaccinés le deuxième rappel correspond à
la quatrième faute pour plus de 20 ans
est ouverte nous allons continuer
notamment dans les ehpad a expliqué
qu'il est important de faire ce deuxième
rappel pour continuer à se protéger
contre le virus et puis les français ont
aussi appris à j'allais dire
réenclencher cette barrière parce que
c'est nécessaire nous arrivons peut-être
au pic de cette septième vague puisque
voilà les chiffres les plus tôt sera sur
un plateau
remettre le masque dans les transports
remettre le masque lorsque nous sommes
dans des endroits fermés et que
la responsabilité de nos concitoyens
elle a été démontrée et on le voit bien
que instinctivement certains leur net où
certains ne l'ont jamais enlevé
d'ailleurs alors un des sujets clivants
ir a été ré intégration des soignants
non vaccinés plusieurs groupes d
opposition vous le demande pourquoi ne
pas le faire aujourd'hui
le ministre de la santé hier soir a
répondu à une question du député du
député de st juste sur ce sujet
d'abord moi je tiens à
féliciter les soignants très nombreux 99
plus de 99% des soignants sont faits ce
sont vaccinés dont on parle entre 2 05
60 des soignants qui ne le sont pas près
de 12000 soignant le ministre hier soir
à une question
du député philippe gosselin à une
réponse très claire il va consulter dans
les prochaines semaines la haute
autorité de santé le conseil le conseil
d'éthique et après en fonction des avis
de la haute autorité est de considérer
avec des tic pouvoir travailler avec les
syndicats et les syndicats les
professionnels et savoir quelle réponse
parce que jusqu'à quand on les suspend
sachant qu'on voit que les vagues se
succèdent et que finalement le covan ne
part pas pour l'instant la vaccination
pour les professionnels restent
obligatoires sont très clairs avec ciné
on le sait c'est ça la limite pour
l'instant la vaccia la vaccination reste
obligatoire le ministre hier soir a
annoncé une méthode
laissons-nous temps de la mettre en
oeuvre mais qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous que ça fait des mois et des mois
qu'ils ne sont pas payés est ce que
finalement ils n'ont pas suffisamment
été mise à l'écart s'est passé pas une
question d'être mis à l'écart ou pas il
y à une loi qui a été qui a été décidée
qui a été voté à l'assemblée nationale
où on faisait appel à la responsabilité
individuelle de chaque personnel
soignant de pouvoir se vacciner d'abord
pour se protéger et pour protéger les
personnels de l'hôpital et aussi pour
protéger les personnes malades qui
arrivait dans les lieux
cette loi elle s'applique aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous disons à virulent est
ce que ne peut pas changer le virus est
moins virulent mais c'est toujours là je
souhaite donc cette loi s'applique
toujours je le redis le ministre hier
soir a annoncé vouloir prendre l'avis de
la haute autorité de santé et du conseil
national d'éthique et en fonction de cet
avis de pouvoir discuter avec les ports
et se convainc donc la porte est ouverte
à une méthode de concertation et de
consultation sur ce sujet et justement
puisque vous parlez du musée la santé
françois bruno rapin de la crise d
urgence simple puisqu'il avait dirigé la
mission flash qui avait été commandée
par emmanuel macron après il est devenu
ministre de la santé est ce que cette
mission flash finalement c'est pas
retardé mise en oeuvre de solutions
alors que les constats on les connaît
notamment le sénat avait déjà rendu
plusieurs rapports sur ce sujet donc la
première ministre elisabeth brawn avait
demandé avec bourguignon alors est
récente puisque c'est françois qui avait
rendu un rapport et y est devenu
ministre quelques jours plus tard de
cette mission flash avaient fait
quarante et une proposition la première
ministre les a retenus tout elles vont
être mi-temps mise en place pourquoi une
mission flash parce qu'effectivement
pour cet été il y avait urgence à
apporter des réponses pour les urgences
ces quarante et une propositions vont
être mises en oeuvre très rapidement
puisque j'allais dire les décrets ont
été signés dès ce week end pour que sur
tous les territoires les ars plus puisse
les mettre en oeuvre en fonction de la
situation de chacune des urgences toutes
les propositions vont être mises en
oeuvre notamment l'idée de fermer les
urgences la nuit c'est pas l'idée de
fermer les urgences et demi c'est je le
je le redis et je crois qu'il faut le
dire est très clair à tous nos
concitoyens toute personne en situation
d'urgence vitale sera prise en charge et
les autres les autres à partir du moment
où les audiences ont fermé on peut faire
le 15 et le 15 répond et réoriente au
havre nous avons et lors de ma première
visite la semaine dernière à visiter le
service d'accès aux soins on appelle le
15 tout de suite en fonction de la
situation qui est décelée par l'agent
régulateur on envoie soit vers la
médecine de ville soit vers les urgences
lorsque c'est nécessaire c'est là qu'il
faut généraliser ce système qui est une
forme finalement de trier de filtres en
tout cas avant les urgences pour vous
généralisée pour cet été cette
faute cette solution est proposée et je
sais que beaucoup d'urgentistes le
demande
mais en tout cas fait le 15 avant de
vous déplacer ça me permettait déjà aux
journaliers surchargées dans certaines
régions donc est-ce qu'il va y avoir des
désaccords d'effectifs pour pour le samu
ou pas aux commandes parce que ça va
être un le maïeur charge mariage le
mariage du smur
est maintenu je le répète il s'agit bien
de répondre à tout besoin de quelqu'un
c'est nos concitoyens qui a besoin d'un
soin une solution sera apporté et je le
redis toutes les personnes en situation
d'urgence vitale seront bien sûr prise
en charge alors plus démunis ce qu on
appelle le 15 et qu'on peut être
réorientés vers la médecine de ville
mais le problème c'est dans beaucoup de
territoires les gens ils vont aux
urgences parce qu'à pas de médecine de
ville comment vous allez résoudre ce
problème les gens vont aux urgences
parce qu'ils n'ont pas pu trouver une
réponse donc je le redis avec le 15 et
le système des services d'accès aux
soins qui sont testés dans plusieurs
départements français on voit bien qu'on
arrive à apporter des réponses d'abord
30 % des appels ne nécessite pas la
visite chez un médecin ou un passage aux
urgences et après on voit bien qu en se
réorganisant avec la médecine de ville
d'où l'intérêt de travailler avec les
médecines de vie mais aussi pour les
possibilités de trains avec des instants
avec d'autres professionnels de santé
pouvoir apporter au point de citoyens
ministres juste
qu'ils sont déjà surchargés comment
faire en sorte d'ouvrir des d'ouvrir des
créneaux c'est j'allais dire une
co-construction et une collaboration
ville hôpital c'est quelque chose dont
on parle depuis depuis très longtemps
et si vous voulez venir voir ça marche
c'est à dire que des médecins de ville
donne des créneaux à ce fameux numéro et
tout de suite on a une réponse mais ça
marche partout pour l'instant c'était un
test en plus dans les drom l'idée c'est
pouvoir de l'évaluation il va être fait
à la rentrée d'évaluer et de peau noire
pour les urgences est en tête dans
plusieurs régions mais cette
articulation entre médecine de vienne et
médecine hospitalière c'est un problème
notamment qui a été mis en lumière jour
là elle se construit elle se construit
elle ce concept est bien on va essayer
de le régler vous avez déjà des
solutions on va pouvoir je ne vais pas
vous tous vous des solutions alors que
l'as la méthode que nous souhaitons
mettre en place c'est bien de travailler
ensemble pour apporter les solutions
pour raconter ce que vous êtes discuter
de tout ça justement et vente est ce que
tout ça va concrètement se mettre en
place écoutez nous sommes en place
depuis une semaine
il était là
les urgences il y a 6 40 est une mesure
qui sont mises en place et déjà les
décrets ont été signés par le ministre
ce week-end pour être mises en
application je vais rencontrer moi très
rapidement toutes les associations
d'élus on va rencontrer tous les
professionnels de santé on va aussi
rencontrer les associations de patients
parce que l'idée de construire ensemble
c'est bien de trouver des solutions qui
puissent mailler le territoire et les
territoires ont des solutions à nous
proposer mais les professionnels ont
aussi à apprendre et on voit bien dans
les parcours coordonné de soins que les
professionnels ont beaucoup appris à
travailler ensemble pendant la crise
sanitaire et l'idée c'est bien de
pouvoir continuer à
inculquer cette méthode
crise elle met d'abord puis il l'a
intitulé qui est quand même un peu
inédit chargé de l'organisation
territoriale et des professionnels de
santé qu'est ce que cela recouvre
exactement
vous l'avez dit vous-même et d'ailleurs
lorsque l'intitulé du ministère danger
bonheur d'avoir la charge
à 7 cette nomination tout le monde à la
résumer à déserts médicaux
à peu près à ce que tous les concitoyens
monde itu tous les collègues
mais voilà c'est à peu près mais je
n'espère pas que de sa
feuille de route va bientôt va bientôt
arriver a sans aucun doute c'est un
sujet qui a été entendu par le président
de la république le fait qu'il nomme
ministre délégué en charge de
l'organisation territoriale c'est un
sujet sur lequel déjà le gouvernement
précédent avait commencé à travailler et
qu'il faut accélérer parce que la
situation est urgente c'est un sujet sur
lequel tous les candidats dernièrement
d'abord à l'élection présidentielle et
ensuite aux élections législatives nous
avons été confrontés que ce soit en
milieu urbain où que ce soit en milieu
rural donc de nombreuses pistes ont été
mises en oeuvre lors du dernier
quinquennat elle ne porte pas encore
leurs fruits le numerus clausus il faut
plusieurs années pour former un médecin
donc la suppression du mur en exclu ce
qu était la première des mesures à
prendre et elle a été prise ne peut pas
encore produire ses effets les
infirmières de pratiques avancées sont
en train d'être mise en place les
assistants médicaux qui permettent de
décharger les médecins d'une partie des
charges administratives sont en train de
se mettre en oeuvre donc on a des pistes
sont déjà là mais en plus il nous faut
apporter avec les collectivités
territoriales avec tous les
professionnels de santé une autre façon
peut-être de travailler ensemble et avec
françois braud nous avons bien
l'intention de faire en sorte que le
ministère de la santé soit ouvert à tous
à toutes les collectivités
avant que toutes ces propositions ne
portent leurs fruits le député mayenne
et yannick favenec qui siège sur les
bancs de la majorité à proposer une loi
pour réguler l'installation des médecins
dans les déserts médicaux est ce que
vous y êtes favorable et est-ce que ça
doit passer par l'assemblée et ce sujet
elles feront martyrs bien sûr des
discussions que nous aurons à voir à la
fois avec tous les professionnels avec
les médecins
on ne peut pas je ne peux pas vous dire
oui ou non tout de suite mais la
problématique est on le sait bien si
cette solution avait marché elle aurait
été mise en oeuvre il y à déjà bien
longtemps donc on voit bien que ce sujet
il revient de façon périodique mais
comme je vous
pour vous je répète le déserts médicaux
ils ne sont pas qu'en milieu rural ils
sont maintenant partout dans toutes les
villes et donc le sujet c'est pas de
savoir si on impose un médecin de
s'installer à un endroit est le sujet
c'est de savoir si sur tout le
territoire français on a une solution et
on offre une réponse à nos concitoyens
pour pouvoir avoir accès aux soins
non quand je te dis que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut discuter à titre
personnel puisque il est d'habitude de
ressortir ce qu'on dit donc je vais
assumer clairement mes propos je dis
bien qu'à titre personnel je n'y suis
pas favorable mais c'est quelque chose
dont on va devoir discuter alors si
incohérente comment si elle peut
insister sur incitation financière si
elle peut apporter une réponse si elle
peut apporter une réponse à certains
territoires pourquoi pas mais c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut discuter et co
construire avec les professionnels eux
mêmes je crois que c'est important de
partager cette idée avec les
professionnels eux-mêmes justement
puisque vous parlez des élus il ya
certaines collectivités qui salarient
des médecins ça me paraît être la bonne
sur le site ulla l'encourager c'est une
des réponses ça marche très bien dans
certains départements parce que certains
certains médecins et notamment des
jeunes médecins souhaitent pouvoir avoir
ce mode d'exercice d'autres le ne
veulent pas donc je crois qu'on ne peut
pas avoir une réponse unique si on a une
réponse unique savent bien qu'on ne
travaille pas avec les territoires les
territoires sont différents les
situations selon les territoires sont
très différents sont est ce que vous
allez commencer vos discussions avec les
élus avec les professionnels
j'ai déjà lancé jallet une invitation à
venir au ministère de la santé quand
vous rencontrez les l'invitation est
parti hier donc pour qu'elle lève je
voulais dire ah bah j'attends les
réponses m'a dit que ce faire se peut
ainsi c'est cette semaine cette semaine
de travail et fasse son travail ce qu'il
faut leur donner plus de compétences en
matière de santé ou est ce qu'il faut
par exemple revoir le mode de
gouvernance des agences régionales de
santé
j'ai fait avec quelques temps un rapport
d'évaluation sur les agences régionales
de santé qui à mon avis ont été
de façon très injuste alors qu'elles ont
fait vraiment face lors de la crise
sanitaire mais tout le monde a découvert
ce qu'était une agence régionale de
santé elles n'ont que dix ans ces
agences régionales de santé elles ont
subi à la fois une crise humanitaire de
plus de deux ans et en même temps un
élargissement de leur champ géographique
donc elles sont devenus des très grosses
machines je pense que les agences
régionales de santé vont aussi devoir
peut-être avoir à travailler un peu plus
en lien et de façon presque permanente
en lien direct avec avec les élus locaux
on voit que c'est ce qui a été fait
pendant ce la crise sanitaire et c'est
ce qui a permis d'apporter des réponses
1 donc là on sent le désir de tout
remettre à plein de tours coordonnées en
discussion avec le maximum de gens le
candidat mc ren avait souhaité que la
question de la santé soient inclus au
conseil national de la refondation est
ce qu il en est toujours question est
est ce que ce conseil national de
réponde à sion est en train d'être mises
en oeuvre ou pas sur le conseil national
de la fondation je laisserai le
président de la république apporter la
réponse en tout cas la mission qui nous
a été confiée c'est dès la rentrée de
faire la conférence des parties
prenantes la conférence des parties
prenantes c'est bien quelque chose que
nous allons construire avec françois
braun sur justement les parties
prenantes elles sont elles sont très
larges et ça concerne tout le monde la
santé concerne tout le monde elles
concernent d'abord les concitoyens elle
conserve bien sûr tous les
professionnels et je dis bien tous les
professionnels elle concerne aussi les
territoires ça veut dire que des
citoyens participeront à ces discussions
on va voir comment on organise ça mais
l'idée c'est bien sûr ça et je le redis
la démocratie sanitaire ça veut dire à
nos yeux quelque chose et donc faire
participer aussi les associations de
santé et donc ce qui représente nos
concitoyens quelque chose qui me semble
important
surman bowden nous reste quelques
minutes on va parler d'autres sujets et
notamment des révélations de la presse
concernant un pacte entre emmanuel
macron über on va écouter puisque
emmanuel macron a réagi hier justement
pour la première fois on écoute mais je
l'assumé à fond et en vous regardant
j'ai vu des chefs d'entreprise étrangers
l'horreur
je les ai vu ça a toujours été officiel
avec des collaborateurs
j'en suis fier si l'on crée des emplois
en france j'y suis je suis hyper fier de
cela et vous savez quoi je leur ferai
demain et après demain très sincèrement
comme disait un de mes prédécesseurs ça
m'en touche une sans bouger l'autre je
vous le dis en toute franchise est ce
qu'un prêt dé on peut dire ça n'est
sûrement pas dans un autre l'a déjà dit
c'est jacques chirac l'avait pas dit
publiquement à des saisies sont les
propos rapportés non mais sur le fond
sur le fond du sujet moi aussi je suis
fier qu'un ministre de l'économie ait
fait ça c'est le rôle d'un ministre de
l'économie comment peut-on reprocher un
ministre de l'économie de rencontrer des
entreprises et de se battre pour que des
entreprises investissent en france et
d'ailleurs on peut se réjouir du succès
de toulouse france qui a lieu il n'y a
pas avant-hier à versailles
terme hubert c'est quand même une
entreprise avec des règles sociales qui
sont un peu particulières c'est
peut-être aussi ça ce qui est reproché à
emmanuel macron c'est pas du tout ça car
prochain est maintenue la con c'est le
fait d'avoir rencontré des entreprises
voilà et il ayant souffert ce que vous
en informer les autres membres du
gouvernement françois hollande a répondu
est-ce que parfois il faut avoir des
négociations secrètes pour aboutir voilà
c'est le rôle là franchement qu'un
ministre de l'économie souhaite faire
venir des entreprises en france souhaite
des investissements en france s'est
pleinement son rôle et et en os en tout
cas moi je le redis je suis fier que le
président de la république ministre de
l'économie les faits votre premier
déplacement en tant que ministre et est
au havre dans votre ville mais c'est
aussi
la ville d'edouard philippe j'ai envie
vous mourrez quel rôle pour lui dans la
future majorité on le voit peu depuis le
second tour des législatives
on l'a beaucoup vu faire campagne pour
le président de la république on l'a
beaucoup vu faire campagne pour tous les
candidats et maintenant de la majorité
est maintenant appelé les français
adhérer à son parti horizon c'est le
début d'émancipation
d'abord je vais revenir sur mon premier
déplacement au havre il est de coutume
qu'on se déplace dans sa ville mais se
trouvent que j'ai la grande chance
d'habiter wars et que le maire de la
ville du havre qui accueille le ministre
en déplacement soit être un philippe
autant vous dire que sur l'ascenseur
émotionnel c'était c'était très fort et
c'est important de le signaler
edouard philippe a créé un parti
politique il n'est pas complètement
anormal qu'après avoir fait je le redis
campagne pour le président de la
république et pour tous les candidats de
la majorité il maintenant une fausse
campagne entre guillemets une campagne
d'adhésion et lance la campagne
d'adhésion
pour son parti politique parce que pour
le coup je peux je peux vous le dire
puisque je participe à l'animation
d'un des 430 comités municipaux au havre
il faudrait se prononcer une forte
volonté de nos concitoyens à vouloir
partager savoir construire à quoi va
servir ce parti pendant cinq ans
produire des idées qu'elle est quelle
est la vocation est d'apporter vous même
la réponse et lorsque j -p lorsque
edouard philippe a lancé son parti
politique il a dit qu'il souhaitait
partager et construire un projet pour la
france c'est ce que à partie c'est ce
que nous faisons dans les tous les
comités municipaux qui travaillent et je
peux vous le dire instruire le projet
alternatif à celui qui existe
aujourd'hui un projet alternatif sur
lequel un projet sur lequel les français
ont voté c'est le projet qui va être mis
en place par le gouvernement auquel deux
ministres horizon appartiennent là il y
a un groupe horizon à l'assemblée qui
est dans la majorité je vous le rappelle
est edouard philippe a créé en parti
politique que le parti politique puisse
continuer à vivre sa vie le semble être
tout à fait naturel est tout à fait sain
pour la démocratie merci n est surement
le bodo merci mon con avoir été notre
invité ce matin christelle on regarde la
une de la dépêche charcuterie le poison
des nitrites c'est à la une de votre
journal merci creissels
[Musique]